going into the show i was pretty excited
i liked the outlandish and unique take
one division had on the superhero genre
and from that i had high hopes for
falcon in the winter soldier
this was going to be a long
well-developed thriller
with engaging and riveting conflicts but
the show as a whole was just very bland
i think the writing is the biggest
culprit here and the formulaic pattern
of the plot became very dull and
repetitive for me
the pattern was find a lead follow up on
it and have an action scene
then the bad guys escape and repeat the
cycle
this basically happened every episode
and by the time the cycle repeated
itself for a third time
it just became very clear that the
show's core dna of plot structure was
flawed
the only interesting development within
this cycle was working with zemo
having a primary villain become an
anti-hero and him ironically becoming
more likable than your primary leads
is pretty impressive and that mostly
goes to daniel broll's portrayal of zemo
which to me is by far the best
aspect of the show but this also
highlights another major issue in that
their primary leads aren't that
captivating
for sam wilson a lot of his conflict
throughout the show derives from just
having a bad relationship with bucky
their overall relationship felt way too
childish at times
like oh hahaha it's so funny that
they're having a steering competition
and then that paired with other scenes
like sam giving bucky the silent
treatment just comes off as immature and
unlikable
i get there's supposed to be tension
between these two characters but
that's not how you go about writing it
for sam's conflict as a whole
only until the last two episodes do the
writers explore the weight of inheriting
the captain america title
as a black man this would have made for
a great internal conflict throughout the
show
but they just passed it off as this
statement for sam not wanting the shield
and steve first told me about the shield
the first words i said were it feels
like it belongs to someone else
so besides the conflict with bucky the
only other main personal dilemmas that
sam has to deal with
is family and monetary issues people
argue that this humanizes sam wilson
and to a degree that's true but the show
spent way too much time in that area
they gave us a big portion of family
drama in the first episode
and then for the fifth episode they
double down and spend like 30 minutes on
that subject
no one wants to watch sam wilson
repairing a boat for almost a whole
episode especially since this happens
before the finale
it's like okay well you're humanizing
this character who while not being a
superhero doesn't have a lot of
interesting things going on
and to contrast this with bucky his
personal dilemma is actually fun to
follow
he has to deal with the mental anguish
of being a mind controlled assassin
and he has to make amends to give
himself internal peace
that is good character development but
for sam it's very bare bones and he's
the lead of the show
and going into sam's monetary conflict
they bring this up in the first episode
about how his family needs more money
and that the banks aren't giving him any
loans in the long run for the show
this conflict doesn't really matter it
feels like a waste of time
a superhero story that uses monetary
conflict correctly
is spider-man for peter parker he has to
balance protecting the city
making money at his job spending time
with his family
and building up a relationship with his
love interest all of these aspects put a
vast amount of tension on his character
because his schedule is so busy and he
has a lot of responsibility
and having to make money adds tension
within that responsibility
for sam wilson him spending time with
his family and worrying about money just
felt like a side objective that felt
largely unnecessary in the overall story
so with the large amount of time they
spent here in the show especially in the
boat repairing episode
i simply just got bored and contemplated
skipping scenes which i never really
want to do
so looking away from the main characters
i want to discuss
the villain i can't really think of a
worse villain
in the mcu than carly morgenthau not
only is she not compelling
but she's also just flat out annoying
there are other villains in the mcu that
are very forgettable like malakith from
thor to the dark world and i'm not even
sure
if that's his name i'm just gonna assume
that's his name
but i don't remember him being annoying
carly on the other hand
is just an emotional teen who stumbled
upon super strength and goes through the
generic the ends justify the mean
scenario
but this time her reasoning doesn't make
sense
you're killing innocent people they're
not innocent
they're roadblocks in my journey and i'd
kill them again if i had to wow
no no no i didn't mean it like that you
tricked me into sounding like like what
this is primarily exposed with sam's
conversation with carly and him trying
to change her mind
which i thought would have been a cool
turn but then that's just interrupted by
a much
needed action scene for whatever reason
john walker had adhd in that moment and
just wanted to bust into the
conversation like the kool-aid man
what would have made more sense was to
have lamar die earlier in the story
thus propelling john walker to not
accept peace
this would have made more sense for him
to interrupt sam in his negotiation with
carly
from there i think the show would have
been a lot better if john walker just
killed the entire organization
and became the primary villain john
walker on his own was an interesting
character study about how our idols and
society are not
flawless and that's how i thought the
show was going until he just turned out
to be good all of a sudden in the final
episode
they literally leave us with him where
he's basically at rock bottom
and then he shows up being a hero at the
end why not explore the corrupt side of
the government
trying to enable a superhuman for their
own benefit
they partially explore this concept with
isaiah bradley and how they buried him
and it would have been more interesting
if it was the same people taking
advantage of john walker
but instead we get a terrorist
organization where even the people
within the organization
seem to be questioning the loyalty to
the cause
so we're working with criminals now also
in what world does a large portion of
the population
support a cause where terrorists are
killing people for it
it just comes off as being very
unrealistic and they had a big missed
opportunity with using john walker as
the primary villain
so in that whole front i think they did
a terrible job
so a big part of the show is the action
and i thought that choreography and
everything on that front was good
but i think the overall set pieces for
the action scenes
were very bland and setting it feels
like a lot of the action
just takes place in doll warehouses
overall set pieces play a large role in
how memorable and grand an action scene
is
but for falcon in the winter soldier
really the only cool action set pieces
were in the first couple of episodes
like the mile high hostage rescue scene
and the fight on the highway
then after that it all just blends
together into boring looking areas
and i guess they maybe did this to save
on their budget but yeah overall
i think falcon in the winter soldier is
overrated given that it has a lot of
high reviews
i'm also someone who tends to really
enjoy superhero movies and shows
but i couldn't really bring myself to
fully enjoy the show
the main redeeming qualities of falcon
in the winter soldier is the cool tying
of the dora melange
john walker being a great villain the
action choreography
and zemo hanging out with the boys i
really like their whole dynamic
although it didn't really feel realistic
at times like when they kept
working with zemo even when he executed
the scientist right in front of bucky
and sam
they kind of dropped that pretty quickly
and they just keep working with him
however the other aspects like the
repetitive plot structure
bland action set pieces the horrible
villain
an uninteresting primary character along
with an annoying relationship with bucky
brought the show down for me
it's enjoyable but it's nowhere near as
good as everyone's saying
i hope you enjoyed the video i also did
a review on wand division which will be
in the end screen
let me know in the comments what you
thought about falcon in the winter
soldier and have a nice day
you